[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt heute mache ich eine
geburtstagstorte für unsere freundin
luisa die wird nämlich drei jahre alt
und sie schaut gerne patrol portal kennt
ihr vielleicht dass es eine kinder
fernsehsendung das sind die helfer auf
vier pfoten das sind so kleine diese
hunde und hier habe ich den charakter
sky nach gemacht als torte und das ist
eine geburtstagstorte die man wirklich
super nachmachen kann und man kann im
prinzip auch jeden charakter den man
gerne machen möchte so in dieser art und
weise machen
die torte habe ich ihnen gefüllt mit
dunklem sache bilden also schoko böden
ich habe eine quark sahne creme eine
weiße ghanas und dann noch eine erdbeer
himbeer frucht einlage also wirklich
auch superfrucht ich super lecker und
die torte also an deko braucht ihr so
ungefähr zwei bis drei stunden zeit mehr
nicht und dann habt ihr diese torte
ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal mit dem
backen an und stellen die sache würden
her für den rührteig verwende ich 71
eine prise salz 120 gramm zucker 170 g
weiche butter 120 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt 7 eigelbe 170 km
herren schokolade 150 gramm mehl ein
bisschen tonkabohne und einen esslöffel
milch für den teig nämlich jetzt zuerst
das eiweiß gibt es eine schüssel und
schlags mit dem salz steif und die
schokolade habe ich bereits in einen
gefrierbeutel gefüllt und einfach ins
heiße wasser gegen so kann sie schon mal
schmelzen und sobald der einschnitt
steif ist kommt der zucker noch dazu und
wird mit eingerührt
und kann jetzt die weiche butter mit dem
puderzucker und im wandel extrem ich
verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich hier ein eigelb nach dem
anderen dazu und dann noch ein bisschen
trank abo-angebote ist ein richtig
richtig tolles gewirkt und passt vor
allem perfekte schokolade
die schokolade habe ich auch dazu
gegeben und jetzt kommt der schnee mit
rein und wir gemeinsam mit dem mehl und
der milch abwechselnd untergehoben
[Musik]
jetzt will ich den teig in meine zwei
backformen ein ich habe die bereits auf
20 cm eingestellt und taxis in zwei
formen damit der teig gleichmäßiger
backt und auch schneller
[Musik]
dies kann der tag schon gebacken werden
und die backzeit nutze ich jetzt aus um
eine weiße glas herzustellen und dafür
hier das rezept bereits auf meinem blog
[Musik]
die tortenböden sind jetzt gut abgekühlt
die garage auch schon hergestellt und
ist auch abgekühlt und jetzt zeige ich
euch mal die zutaten für die creme für
die creme verwende ich 500 gramm
magerquark 250 gramm frischkäse etwas
meinl extrakt 70 gramm puderzucker 400
milliliter sahne etwas zitronensaft und
salat
es kommt der magerquark gemeinsam mit
dem frischkäse in der rührschüssel
puderzucker dazu dann etwas wenn ihr
extrakt und zitronensaft
da kann ich die zutaten erstmal
verrühren
[Musik]
da gehe ich auf die sahne dazu und da
kommt sonderfahrt mit rein und die creme
können steif geschlagen werden
die gräben sind fertig die ständig kurz
in den kühlschrank und zeigen euch die
zutaten für die füllung für die
fruchtbildung verwende ich 400 gramm
tief gefrorene früchte dann nämlich
jetzt erdbeeren und himbeeren las sie
gleich auftauen
ich habe ich sieben gramm agger und
etwas man extrakt
die früchte habe ich aufbauen lassen und
habe sie jetzt püriert jetzt kommen sich
in den topf und werden jetzt gemeinsam
mit dem vanille extra zum ärger verrührt
und dann lasse ich die masse aufkochen
und zwei minuten lang spur ihn kochen
und hier kann ich jetzt bereits die
weiße streichfähige garage in einen
spritzbeutel füllen
damit werde ich die torte nämlich
isolieren und diese isolierung brauche
ich auch damit die sahne füllung nicht
an den vom tor gelangt deswegen decker
marc schramm
[Musik]
jackpot mit 20 cm durchmesser
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen was von der
anna straub einfach damit die torte hier
nicht runter rutscht dann nehme ich den
ersten boden
ich habe den tortenboden einfach jeweils
einmal durchgeschnitten da kommt es hier
ein sauberer trocken ring aus warum wir
jetzt nämlich hier die garagen
spritzbeutel und spritzt ihr außen einen
isolierband und den ziehe ich hier am
rand einfach ein bisschen hoch bis hin
glatt streichen
und jetzt kann hier in die quark sahne
rein
ich habe vier tortenböden also kommt
jetzt hier etwa ein drittel der creme
rein dann vorsichtig verstreichen
jetzt kommt ja auch ein drittel der
frucht füllung drauf die darf natürlich
nicht mehr heiß sein
dann konnte nächste tortenboden drauf
und so wird dann die gesamte torte
gefüllt
[Musik]
so kann man sich den tortenring
hochbauten also 2 cm bräuchte ich da
jetzt echt noch aber ich habe jetzt
einfach danach streben ein bisschen
höher gemacht dann passt jetzt nämlich
auch noch die frucht einen lagerraum
ich setze die übrigens immer ganz gerne
hier auch so ein quatsch
so könnt ihr nämlich schneller ab und
ich habe aber die kontrolle darüber
wenn ich nämlich in den kühlschrank
stellen dann vergesse ich sie mal ganz
schnell und dann wird es schnell fest
letzte frucht einlage und letzter
trockenboden
[Musik]
das hätte ich gerne noch einen torten
retter drauf und dann konnte ich immer
noch gerne mit der wasserwaage ob die
torte gerade ist und dann den rand
einfach ganz corp glatt streichen und
die torte dann für mindestens vier bis
fünf stunden kühl stellen
[Musik]
die torte ist es gekühlt ich habe die
sprünge waren zweites mal gemacht und
zwar um euch zu zeigen wenn man die
torte besser aus dem tortenring lösen
kann wenn ihr dann nämlich vorher einen
wachs papierstreifen zum beispiel in den
tortenring geht der tortenring super
einfach raus oder können doch ganz
einfach backpapier nehmen und das
zuschneiden
ansonsten ist nämlich ein bisschen
schwieriger getötet da rauszubekommen
jetzt nehme ich einfach die restliche
kader streicht sie auf die torte und
streicht die torte komplett glatt
und ich nehme jetzt hier eine zweite
platte obendrauf die hat auch den
gleichen durchmesser wie das skateboard
unten dran das ist so ein garching board
und damit kann ich jetzt die torte schön
glatt streichen so dass er auch an den
seiten wirklich rechtwinklig ist jetzt
nehme ich einfach meine palette und
streicht hier die restliche garage an
den rand und kann dann die torte mit der
tankkarte glatt ziehen
echt super einfach
wenn ihr dann die torte abgezogen habt
könnt ihr einfach noch diese kleinen
lücken die hier zwischendurch entstehen
film noch mal abziehen und dann ist es
schon perfekt glatt
[Musik]
die tat habe ich jetzt kühl gestellt
jetzt kommt die deko an die reihe
übrigens steht hier katja sind da macht
mir meinen hustenmittel was machst du
irgendwie zitrone zum aktiven politikern
ist ganz natürlich und ich hab jetzt
hier weißen fondant hab hier braunen von
dann ist das schokoladen fondant und ich
versuche jetzt einfach diese helle farbe
ins gesicht zu machen und eventuell
brauche ich noch ein bisschen gelbe
lebensmittel passten farbe
habe ich meinen gewünschten farbton
erreicht ich habe noch ein bisschen rot
und geld rein als ich das so ein
bisschen ein hellerer version von orange
und ich brauche ich hier drei farbtöne
ich habe nämlich hier einmal das helle
gesicht von sky dann die hellere
schnauze und die dunkleren ohren und
augen und das ist jetzt der mittlere
teil
das nehme ich hier die torte stuhls mit
etwas back trance dre
so klebt der von dann nämlich besser an
der torte und es entstehen keine
luftbläschen und dann einfach die von
der decke drüber legen und glatt
streichen
und jetzt die reste wegschneiden
die brauche ich gleich noch
und ist heute völlig streichen
nämlich runde die kante jetzt so ein
bisschen ab normalerweise mag ich sehr
gerne wenn die torten ein bisschen eckig
sind oben aber zur sky passt
abgerundeten ein bisschen besser jetzt
das gesicht an der reihe und ich habe
mir schablonen gemacht und zwar einmal
was größeres für die augen einmal möchte
ich hier den dunklen ringen hinter den
augen dann das weiße von den augen an
sich und die schnauze freue mich ja auch
ein bisschen und jetzt nämlich einfach
den dunkleren farbton soll den aus
mit essbarem kleber kann ich immer alles
schön ankleben
mit hier einfach schön mit den fingern
den rand so ein bisschen ausdünnen und
beim zweiten auge muss ich natürlich
erst mal überlegen wo das auge hin kommt
in die mitte kommt ja noch die nase die
schnauze einfach mal am besten hinhalten
[Musik]
muss nämlich einfach ein modell werkzeug
und streicht es hier noch so ein
bisschen an den rand und franz ist auch
ein bisschen aus das ist halt echt
aussieht wie viel da kommt jetzt der
weiße bart den markiere ich mir jetzt
kurz drücken dann vorsichtig einen so
bekommt ein bisschen tiefe
dem rat kann jetzt auch ausschneiden
[Musik]
und dort dann weiß einsetzen
habe ich hier den hälften ton damit wird
es schnauze geformt dass ich brauch oben
in der mitte so eine kleine schnauze da
geht ja das fell so ein bisschen hell
nach oben und dann ja so ein bisschen
die wangen formen und daneben das
lächeln reindrücken
das freue mich jetzt einfach mal so frei
schnauze als mir dran und den rest kann
ich dann unten einfach wegschneiden
ich freue mich dass hier die wange noch
so ein bisschen nach oben dass sie mehr
richtung augen gehen einfach so mit den
fingern ein bisschen entlang drücken
jetzt brauche ich noch skies nase dafür
habe ich ein bisschen dunkelbraun phorms
in der hand zu einer kugel und dann so
ein bisschen dreieckig und dann kann ich
die nase auch direkt an kleben
jetzt nehme ich einen runden ausstecher
und drücke dann noch den mund ein
jetzt ins gleis augen an der reihe dafür
habe ich jetzt hier wieder ein bisschen
dunkles lila ausgerollt schwarz und weiß
und nehmen jetzt einfach diese lockten
zum ausstechen
eine etwas größere wir die pinkfarbene
iris und dann die mittelgroße für die
schwarze profile und kleine weiße kreise
für die lichtpunkte
[Musik]
sieht schon mal ganz anders aus mit
augen
ich finde ohne auge sieht es immer so na
ja gruselig und für die wimpern dem ich
jetzt ein bisschen schwarz und rolf zu
einem langen strang
die enten sind jetzt hier ganz schön und
dann klebe ich hier die wimpern an und
macht dann noch eine kleinere wurst für
die augenbrauen
mit sieht man hier auch ganz gut dass
gerade die kleinen details wirklich so
auf den gesichtsausdruck ausmachen also
an den details könnt euch echt so ein
bisschen festsetzen und können daran
arbeiten und dann sieht die torte echt
immer genial aus die an den rand setze
ich jetzt noch zwei kleine wimpern dafür
auch eine ganz kleine wurst dann in der
mitte umknicken
und dann noch mal in die ecke rein
kriegen
ich glaube ich habe hier die erste
wimpern verlängerung für runde gemacht
verlängerung und verdichtung ja du
kannst tragen sky
jetzt fahre ich noch geist brille die
sitzt ja immer so auf dem kopf hier
hinter den ohren und dafür habe ich
jetzt ein stück papier zugeschnitten und
zwar geht es von der mitte aus gesehen
so ein bisschen weiter als bis zum ende
der torte jetzt gleich die torte in den
kühlschrank stellen und damit eine
schablone für die brille machen habe ich
hier ein bisschen pink und lila rolle
schön dünn aus
und es muss jetzt einfach lang genug
sein so dass die schablone zweimal drauf
passt es schneide ich erstmal den
unteren streifen zu den rosinen streifen
schneiden wir sind bereit dazu und den
lianen und ein bisschen dünner mit denen
eben aussieht wenn ich mir oben drauf
klebt
[Musik]
schneide ich einfach mit bisschen puffer
und den rand weg ein geber großzügig
lassen weil wegschneiden kann ich ja
immer noch das wirklich kurz zur seite
jetzt soll ich noch mal ein bisschen
villa aus dieses mal drei millimeter
dick
[Musik]
es mache ich zwei große kreise
und zwei kleinere
und die kleineren klebe ich jetzt auf
die großen drauf
[Musik]
jetzt sehe ich den kleineren ausstecher
steckt das jetzt hier aus mit sky eben
auch durch gucken kann
wobei sie die brille eigentlich nie
benutzt den rahmen den brauch jetzt
haben die was gelernt
ich mache noch das verbindungsstück das
heißt steht sagt zumindest der mann
hinter der kamera
wenn es nicht stimmt dann beschwert
haben
[Musik]
jetzt setzt sich die torte auf ein
kickboard das skateboard habe ich schon
mit pinkfarbenem fondant überzogen und
so ein bisschen mit einer struktur
roller strukturiert jetzt lebe ich die
torte mit etwas ganz fest und zwar nicht
ganz in der mitte sondern ein bisschen
weiter nach hinten versetzt damit ich
noch platz für den namen als für die usa
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das berühmt es läge jetzt
erstmal nur hin und ich gebe es noch
nicht
[Musik]
brillengläser jetzt kann ich die brille
ein bisschen nach vorne nichts diese ein
bisschen nach vorne denn die ohren
müssen ja noch hinten dran
[Musik]
krebs noch nicht was erst jetzt freu'
mich noch die ohren dafür nehme ich
jetzt die dunkle farbe den dunkelsten
ton also denen von den augen shoppen und
gucke jetzt erst mal wegen der größe ich
denke dürfen zu sein
das war direkt zur tropfenförmig jetzt
das ohr formen schön flach drücken oder
rollen und dann habt ihr so ja so
eingedrückte deswegen drücke ich das
jetzt hier einfach mit dem messer ein
wieso kleine frau dann kann ich sagen
kleben
jetzt fehlen uns gar hiervon noch die
haare
dafür nämlich die restliche dunkle farbe
bevor man auch so kleine tröpfchen und
die klebe ich dann übereinander hier
vorne hin
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich das tor noch den letzten
feinschliff natürlich musste auch der
name des geburtstagskindes drauf also
luisa ich habe hier meine buchstaben
ausstecher direkt auf das skateboard
gelegt und drückt die so ein bisschen
ein
und damit man den namen besser sehen und
lesen kann
zumal es noch mit metallic farben
schwarz und dieses schwarz benutze ich
dann auch noch ein bisschen für die nase
und für die pupille
[Musik]
wenn jetzt noch das letzte finish die
sonnenbrille gefällt mir ist so zwar
schon gut aber ich hoffe mir sie jetzt
noch ein bisschen und habe noch mal zwei
kreise ausgestochen diesmal in schwarz
und jetzt kann ich hier die metallic
farben nehmen und verspiegelte gläser
machen
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt noch drei kerzen rein
gesteckt ich hier oben rein dann freut
sich die luisa denz darauf bloß bedarf
[Musik]
ja das ist die torte für luisa luisa
wenn du dieses video irgendwann sie ich
wünsche dir alles liebe und gute zu
deinem geburtstag und ich freue mich
schon mal für kinder geburtstagsparty
da machen wir ein paar coole spiele hat
er auch schon gesagt er freut sich auch
schon riesig darauf falls ihr die torte
nach machen möchtet dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei ihr könnt natürlich
alles was ihr seht auch abwandeln die
füllung den teig die creme ihr könnt
alles nach eurem geschmack variieren und
die rezepte gibt es natürlich so zum
nachlesen auf see ließ - blog.de ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
und schreibt mir doch mal welchen film
charakter seriencharakter oder auch
solchen charakter ihr gerne mal als
tochter sehen möchte
da freue ich mich schon drauf und wir
sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]